life has changed so much
kourtney kardashian and addison ray's
friendship is stronger
than ever seriously this is some major
bff-ish
yeah it's crazy the 19-year-old
tick-tock standout and the 41 year old
reality star had a little fun
in the sun over the weekend lounging by
the pool and
posing in bikinis during a getaway to
palm springs california
court shared these shots on instagram
that's the mom of three in a teal
two-piece and a wide-brimmed hat
standing with a polaroid camera over
addison who was
rocking a bright purple bikini her
caption
picture me i picture you and when one
fan asked if she could be friends with
them court responded quote accepting
applications for camp courtney
i'm a fan girl like for sure as for
addison she shared
this tick tock video in the pool lip
syncing along to abbas lay all your love
on me
quartz pal simon huck shot the whole
thing and his fiance phil
blessed us with a little behind the
scenes look on his insta story
simon shared this video of phil along
with court and addison hanging out in
the kitchen
there's court mixing up something to
drink phil also shared
this pool shot with the besties snacking
on some yummy watermelon
i mean i think it's so cool of course
this isn't the first time addison and
court have hung out
like not even close i love it addison
who is the second most followed star on
the social media platform with
over 57 million followers teamed up with
the kardashians on tick tock in july
sharing this clip featuring a swarm of
members from the famous
like fans yeah don't blink or you might
miss
courtney scott disick their kids
penelope and mason
kim and kanye's daughter north and a few
other pals
addison also shared this video
that's the teen rocking some serious
choreo with scott disick
well at least trying to i'm like
watching the kardashians and i'm like oh
my gosh
i wonder what that'd be like to
experience that and so i i like i get it
and um it is crazy that i'm in that
position now in june
court and addison served up some major
keeping up with the kardashians
nostalgia
i just cry myself to sleep every night
reenacting
that scene from the fam's hit reality
show
i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal oh and they
tick-tocked
the hell out of this mother-daughter
moment between khloe kardashian and kris
jenner too
you know where thong i mean not not in
public
oh wow you are conservative
the bffs did some choreo in the closet
and addison even linked up with court's
ten-year-old son mason
who showed off his moves
before all that court invited the tick
tock star to collab on a push video
where addison broke down her signature
booty workout
i start feeling it so much on the fire
hydrants like my side butt is just
burning good thing i did not do butt
yesterday
when e.t caught up with addison in
february court's little sister kendall
had just started following the teen on
tick-tock
and addison was shook kendall jenner
just recently joined tick tock yeah
like yesterday she followed me that's so
cool
i don't it's so cool i don't know i was
like what the heck
and in june when it spoke with addison's
rumored beau bryce hall
he gave his two cents on addison and
court's newfound friendship
what do you think of her videos with
kourtney kardashian when the heck did
she start hanging out with the
kardashians i right you guys really are
that
big though like the kardashians are
trying i'm not hanging out with the
kardashians i'm not
that you haven't gotten invited yet yeah
no i'm i'm waiting for hey kylie
what's up i'm waiting for a party invite
you